arranca la Cumbre iberoamericana con la
reunión de ministros de exteriores con
algunos temas básicamente cuatro muy
amarcados en la agenda oficial como son
la digitalización el combate contra el
cambio climático contra la inseguridad
alimentaria y la petición de una nueva
arquitectura financiera para que los
países de la región puedan acceder más
fácilmente a préstamos y créditos
internacionales un punto que todavía no
ha encontrado consenso entre los
distintos países según nos comentaron
ayer fuentes de distintas delegaciones
Pero por otro lado hay temas que aunque
no estén oficialmente en la agenda son
ineludibles en una reunión de
mandatarios latinoamericanos como es por
ejemplo la migración Y esta es una
cuestión sino la principal que quiere
poner sobre la mesa del presidente
chileno Gabriel borich está también la
relación con la Unión Europea recordemos
que este Cumbre asiste también
alto comisionado de la Unión Europea
para los asuntos exteriores también está
la cooperación para para combatir el
crimen internacional y en un evento así
evidentemente se observa con lupa la
asistencia o la ausencia de distintos
mandatarios y entre las más
significativas por su protagonismo en la
actualidad regional está la de la
presidenta la ausencia de la presidenta
de Perú Dina boluarte está también la
ausencia del presidente del Salvador
naship bukele pero también la del
presidente de Brasil Luis Ignacio Lula
da Silva por una incompatibilidad de
agenda con su viaje a China y ayer
precisamente hablamos con la delegación
de Brasil a raíz del comentario que hizo
Alberto Fernández de que Argentina iba a
volver a la unasur en esos momentos
saltó a la prensa que Brasil también
oficializaría su vuelta a este organismo
de cooperación regional en el marco de
esta Cumbre pero no respondieron ayer
personas de la delegación de Brasil que
quedan muchos esfuerzos por hacer para
que la unasur vuelva a la vida